cette année on voudrait réunir
l'ensemble des familles autour d'un
projet dessin pour pouvoir voir s'animer
les créations la famille noël antillaise
c'est le thème parce qu'effectivement
généralement nous proposons de
dessiner des éléments de la composition
de noël est là l'idée c'est de renouer
un petit peu d'encourager les
et les autres à faire ensemble quels
sont les critères d'âge cette année
justement nous avons ouvert jusqu'à 99
ans de quatre ans à 99 ans donc ça veut
dire que maman papa avec son avec les
enfants mamie tout le monde peut
participer
nous arrêtons la sélection le 1er
décembre pour pouvoir choisir les 3 mai
trois catégories de dessins qui seront
imprimées et ses trois dessins pourront
être vues dans un dessin animé réalisé
par des jeunes en les jeunes de bons
calicots à partir du 12 12 décembre
plusieurs de gestion d'année en année et
de plus en plus de participants le
succès les jeunes adorent facilement
ben oui grâce à ben le web nous avons
choisi justement de faire ce partenariat
avec le web de martinique 1ère et
effectivement les gens apprécient et les
enfants de toute façon sont les premiers
à participer et cette année nous
espérons que les parents vont se jeter à
l'eau aussi alors participer c'est
simple il faut prendre un crayon de la
couleur une feuille et s'exprimer et
s'exprimer avec avec toute sincérité